next year systems is a toronto-based
software company we provide intelligent
customer management solutions to
financial services companies around the
world we do business in North America
your Asia and Europe and the Middle East
over the last few years the customers
are looking for more out-of-the-box less
customized solutions and to deliver that
we are investing in hybrid cloud
solutions where we offer the solution as
a managed service to our customers we
chose IBM because as a very strong
hybrid cloud offering focused around
data integration they have a consistent
infrastructure in data centers around
the world so that we can offer a managed
service to our customers and still
comply with their data residency
requirements our objective is to be able
to deploy a solution to our customers in
about 15 to 20 percent of the time that
we could in the past so dramatically
reduce our our cost of implementation
and time to market the infrastructure
offerings themselves give us the
flexibility in power that we need to be
able to tailor the solutions to the
requirements of our clients whether it's
a shared infrastructure or a dedicated
private infrastructure we can do it both
with our same product offering on the
IBM cloud enabling inteligentes within
our system and focused around not
removing the adviser or the end user
from the picture and replacing them but
augmenting him with better information
better suggestions of what to do and why
to do it
enabling him to do his job better and
faster because next Jay is required to
provide a mission critical application
that meets the compliance and regulatory
standards of our customer we need a
infrastructure that supports it and IBM
does that
[Music]